so here we go ones on final time again
that's 20 seconds to go the saturday
evening war zone so usually those are
quite strong the weekend tourneys sunday
i'm especially but saturday not best bet
as well so let's see what happens i
don't think i have a oops i actually
need to hit enter I don't think I'm I
ever did a video on on the wasn't final
that actually won I've won quite a lot
of these but I don't think gabba to the
video when i won so let's see what
happens what happens is the game does
not start come on there are some
technical things are really annoying
sometimes I want to adjust the window a
bit I hope yeah
isn't it great it happens on the first
game this kind of no game started well
at least them that gives me a few
seconds to fetch me some water be back
in a second you all this was not what I
was hoping for so maybe the second game
gets started
yeah doesn't look like it gets started
oh my yeah I hope you enjoyed the video
so far two minutes 20 seconds of waiting
in the meantime we'll actually have a
minus score this is just brilliant I
have a minus score why do I have a minus
score I mean my connections this is just
fine and this is not starting cool so
I'll wait a bit so if I also lose this
game for whatever reason now he tries to
sort starting the third game what
1-2 it gets better and better
yeah and it's summer also cannot start
this game
okay in the first the fourth game it
tries to start I mean do you want to I'm
on minus 3 now I am actually
second-to-last now and this is a joke
right yeah people suggest to relock we
look any I can try that
so let's try see what happens now
back here let's see what happens now I'm
on minus 3 enter already five minutes
past I'm getting a game alright so let's
see if I can okay after he resigned I'm
1-3 brilliant so um ok I'm six minutes
down and on minus three mm-hmm some guys
have already won two games well let's
see what happens next hmm
okay the only chance is some kind of
quick win cm so I'm trying to get
something going quickly here this is
maybe the greatest stuff around but it
tries to win the game quickly okay what
can you do king e6 okay okay and then I
grab it
yeah I've got quite some stuff on f6
here
yeah okay the tool this was quick so
among I've got one point now maybe
chances to catch up here k so four
nights game here try on this line to
stir up some trouble if possible Knight
g4 stuff not immediately of course but
after g6 I can try and try something
like this okay here we go Quinn edge
form this isn't so I mean it is cruel
yeah but it's not entirely pointless
because some I'm really getting close to
white skin here you should age three now
as a threat Bishop a 3g takes 83 Queen
g3 right some this winter I mean not
winning but I get to get lots of points
now and his King is wide open
of course I don't want to draw some will
be activate the rook this was nice so I
should try to get down get to his skin
quickly okay so i don't mind afghan
three pawns up in the end game I mean so
nice to to checkmate but this is also
easy to hard to spoil
if I play our all moves almost instantly
then this should be quick enough as well
I did I don't need to think here just
and push the pawns all right so I'm on
third place this is nice catching up
quickly here don't want to think about
what what happened would have happened
with six extra minutes k e form i need
to still get in some quick wins so okay
no move I mean he accepted the doubling
cube and now it's not moving okay
yeah this is this line don't know it
really i think this is already not the
best but it looks easy to play for wild
Quincy 7 ourselves less is better maybe
but this is sewn should be okay don't
mind this position now look at form and
have some play against f 6 cm the output
of success is a problem frame we will
win this pawn okay so i can actually
take here one another pawn so okay
thanks he resigned someone first play is
cool so this rocky start didn't really
mean much yeah some exchange rule Lopez
here Oh John i blundered e5 but he
didn't take it oops I need to meet more
precisely i wanted to play g6 okay so
nothing nothing really bad happened but
it wasn't the move I intended right okay
I'll take this so 94 maybe
okay now just back trying to sacrifice
on b3 this could be dangerous okay let's
protect the pawn maybe at some point you
will even take it so need to protect
itself take here so I'm porn up and it's
not the greatest porn ever but it sits
upon and I've got active pieces here not
especially okay I grab grab a second
porn
so how should I continue here i can just
exchange stuff down she wouldn't be bad
maybe gain some space here oh I didn't
didn't take that into account don't have
so many squares okay mm-hmm not sure
that this was was also great okay but
this is ok now I think this would be
four points until they're quite quite
advanced already so I should be some
chances him want to get back to sir
Knight is a good piece and now King to
ya possible I want to get the King to
see five yep King to see five and then
before I can play g5 hmm didn't really
look at this song it's still nothing
terrible I think what could have played
better most likely okay it's four points
which is not bad
and I've got a pretty pretty nicely
positioned King here right in the middle
of the board
ok this is ok that's it this is easiest
three extra points now I'm keen to came
to be funded that the dip should be
enough yam right c3 check check here and
I've got a new queen and made ya find
some my fault myself out of this was not
this ninth with all the pawns was not
one hundred percent clear ok some so
kind of bogo Indian set up here ok
transposase now to a Dutch kind of
position
yeah like us usually find in those kind
of kind of setups can should be four
would be normal 94 you can also play of
it okay if I if I don't mind so much
threatening 95
and again yeah okay wanted to provoke
him a bit but this was very successful
pro provocation so to say winning this
this pawn here they can also grab the
exchange think I should I should do that
okay now let's open it up here GTX fi
can take the rook because of the long
diagonal and now i can double on the FR
there should be nice so now we form and
we drop drop this back this piece wasn't
doing anything and it still a bit tight
down here night cannot really move
yeah don't want to really it's a bit
annoying here maybe I did something
wrong takes with the king yeah but Quinn
2e2 should should cover everything still
this looks a bit a bit uncomfortable I
want to play with d3 g.r three hmm maybe
this this helps to to clarify matters
here now I can I could actually take you
i can take this
Queen back can see this looks quite
secure now I completely forgot to look
at the clock down to nine seconds and
because this is the only way to to not
win the game to lose on time
stupid yeah completely idiotic I didn't
look at the clock at all only way only
way to lose this game yeah he's posting
yes yeah learn to play chess for wine
for once erotic yeah I'm sorry but then
I just didn't look at the clock which is
of course my own fault but really no
reason to celebrate if you play like a
complete [ __ ] and then win on time
alright so we have from rue la paz
exchange here one of my somewhat weird
sidelines that I play in the exchange
and I already have some trouble here it
looks like okay well it's a the benefit
of this this kind of line is so it's
some it's quite quite interesting oh my
god phone call great yeah okay okay so
let's so by I can do something in this
game usually if I get a phone call
during a chess game I always lose
because it's tiny irritates me
okay so it's nothing much going on here
only a couple of exchanges and i'm left
with bishop against night which should
should be fine for me unless some
there's something special going on here
okay so i want to drag queens he doesn't
but what is he doing on rooty form needs
to play some pretty strange move to not
exchange quincy ok so here now maybe I
can play something like a form
you have the game before forgetting
about the clock is of course really bad
sometimes happens to me because I'm so
we're trying to find good moves usually
and need some time for this and then I
don't pay attention to the clock
sometimes okay so he's coming to have
six but I hope it doesn't matter so much
I mean he needs to be conscious here
maybe now if I have a weakness to check
on b5 okay so i can just win this poor
not okay
can check this
oh what a strange position this should
be ok i might be 79 you should see six
yeah all right ok some third places this
loss loss instead of a win on time
really really costs it's a long game and
intend to loss and well ok so let's see
what happens here got some Slovaks
change Quincy ate a sound quite strange
move Wow
so he's got a hard time now protecting
c6 really how should you protect this
not sure this Bishop f4 is also very
strong piece preventing all kinds of
rupee aid and whatever silver take now
he's got Queen d7 I could play we should
be five at this point okay let's just
exchange Queens also not bad so I'm
going to temple here and one here ok so
just here i am and Bishop d3
so okay maybe four and Roxy one this
looks good if ok so maybe maybe here on
e 5 ft 5 look on the seven down also not
bad at all here yeah this looks very
nice not I should I take em on both
moves one okay so winning king and porn
end game
I just have to postpone coming up and
can also make some movie on the Kings
side okay so I'm catching up here some
guys house leading that I don't know
okay so
play this an old man only check been
only set up to serve me quite well and
blitz games one reason is that you can
very often on play moves quickly ok
let's block the queenside my name place
on the King side anyway so don't mind
this configuration here ok I know f5 f5
coming up
maybe he can sex um somewhere here okay
so no okay but maybe here and in turn
not yet where do you go now with the
Queen no well but I lose the six okay oh
it doesn't take it it wouldn't have been
a disaster but bitten uncomfortable they
are the only issues of course the
position is somewhat closed
yeah the winning plan here's some peace
second reform in the two second reform
Bishop g4 first protective six and then
now maybe I can I can do more
preparation really cannot do anything
anyway so maybe even here this is better
group g3 and then okay so take him
before coming up
so I like to read The King also you
cannot move anyway ok and now i have
three mmmm pushing pawns night h2 mate
still amid so I'm on second place oops
this was quick nice once in a while so
first place for a while ok I've got the
Scotch in my special line that we should
deform yeah always nice to have a really
crude threat once in a while mm-hmm I
can take on f2 yeah why not
ok so he might he might catch the night
but even then I've got quite some
material come on yeah I've got a phone
call again and this is just ridiculous
but the third of it because it's not
starting yeah then I'm getting phone
calls and whatever okay so what what
actually what is this I've got a rook
and pawn against two minor pieces so
it's not too bad materials from Terry
point of view ok so it gave me be too
which is nice and also grab this here
ok so I'm pushing the a porn ok resign
dolly this is nice so 28 minutes left
and um I'm at the top at the moment
right so I'm trying to play some quite a
line against the fresh new coffee em was
more of an accident then if the
conscious conscious decision but it
should be I shouldn't be too bad for me
so White's idea is to play on the
queenside and what should be seven ok
but we had a small expecting a 50 596
awesome ok it's not terrible but turn
start strange so my dear supply c5 and
term i think i will i will play this
next move not quite sure oh you could
prevent this the African can play it
anyway it takes you five this year and
the Queen doesn't have a good square
Quincy 6f could be five queen b 6i can
take now can take also
okay so this should be here so i can i
could give this check it shouldn't be
should be bad and now here ideas of just
taking yeah just grabbing bishop pair
bishop deform so could also just play
Knight b6 here not bad oh i didn't
really look at at the rook that the rook
could take some of course i'm much
better than taking what the Queen all
right no big deal but should have really
considered this okay yeah this is also
not a threat rating but annoying well I
can get rid of the bishop place III I
can take with the Queen I think I hope
I'm not overlooking something it's it's
quite dangerous know that I look at it
more closely okay
yeah but now I can just take here right
now I've got d7 coming up t seven seas 6
this this isn't so so much of a problem
the time of the time is the issue as
usual
we have managed to really accelerate at
the end so okay so what now like I'm
still in the lead so right I think we
got some sort of reversed tirage here
but it's played c5 which is a bit
uncommon taking okay so maybe if I vm
come on let's open the position I like
it when the position opens up here now I
can can just take right 94 not bad
indeed vivitek here it takes on c3 I
mean I'll see six of course and maybe
maybe I can grab here it takes be some
rugby aid and takes on veto or maybe I
take if you take the first
quite a strange strange position maybe
this is so I don't think this is really
good for me okay but this might help
what now here i will threatening Bishop
87 maybe how to how to make progress
here in this position
that's not easy for him either but I can
just take this Wow okay maybe maybe
exchange one rookie yeah this wasn't
such a great great player all this yeah
I should have played just normal stuff
not not allowing this crap on b7 I mean
I could have just just one material yeah
and I saw I don't not quite sure what
he's doing here but could have won like
three times already but taking on was
just taking but it's so bad you can play
anything okay come on I resigned this he
might manage this okay so so eight
minutes to go i am actually playing a
closer pursuer here just seven points
down
so some sideline of the carrots attack
and I already think I'm somehow watch
Duluth order okay but this isn't the
reputation of my plate I'm pretty sure
should should just be nice for me yeah
this is nice for me it was very very bad
anyway don't like but this is of course
helpful I don't really get why doesn't
resign
I have my I have my problems also what
with resigning but I mean it's so lost
so absolutely zero hope that that I can
make a mistake here so i'm not sure why
it doesn't resign ok so here we go it's
all pretty close here let's start a call
the guy again I want with them check
benoni before so try it again ok trying
to get rid of this this Bishop which was
working
yeah this Queen g5 movie did this before
in the game in the earlier game you
played this also and they don't get this
movie at all not sure what really what
what it is doing just weakening squares
and whatever yeah it's already quite
nice for me
no not f6 and the other night to age 5
was very very nice of him here it's
really helping so let's get here so I've
got the hulking side I'm closed so let's
open the Queen side now Queen 85 our
plane and this is all protected here
queen bee three threaten now will be 3 2
b 2 and so on now walk a 3 is also quite
some threat okay nice one so right it's
close I can do it but it's really close
yeah I have such your score with the
exchange laughs it's really really weird
okay so okay then i take the exchange
thought he would tend to this threat
some home but they didn't
yeah and I'm also keeping an active
position which is important my king king
position is a bit with weekend of course
but the only has a check on g5 and I can
exchange ruegg also so it's some way to
maybe this move here this looks good I
think it needs to take on sun see it now
or allow me to exchange Queens and if it
takes on c8 I get yeah we'll see it now
I get to play this here and this helps
could have gone to our five but ok it's
it's a winning end game at least ok so
still on first place
okay so I opened up the position maybe
this was a bit premature but it's not
bad but it's not like bringing you chure
benefits to my position okay I like
those long Queen wolves I admit it okay
come on maybe this is complete nonsense
but he wants to exchange Queens I don't
so no route 85 this was one idea but
maybe I've got something else rookie to
looking to maybe
yeah this is not the kind of super
correct sacrifice but it's it's
dangerous in a way so just go here and
see what is doing now hmm
okay now i'm winning lots of material
the Queen that's most important piece
all right okay so still leading 11
minutes to go okay so Scandinavian this
this weird line with 26 no idea about
this but this looks like pretty normal
position well why should have a slight
advantage
yeah I like this now so some some space
advantage whoops what
where you at now 26 mg6 should be nice
Bishop f4 Bishop g5 stuff like this may
be here this is with tempo and I can
maybe just take a plane 95 95 is also a
good move I think it doesn't really have
a good square for the Queen oh he's got
this mm-hmm this annoying so what is
this he's got three points no yeah crap
i really should have prevented this okay
if five I want to prevent if five if
possible my father prevented it but
maybe I didn't okay can can take even on
b2 now
yeah he's got very lots of poems
okay i managed to grab p 7 & a 6 this is
nice
and now I've got the a poem hopefully
advancing okay I've got a bishop here
okay for points1 on some guys it's very
close here it's really matter of winning
quick here okay try some oops over a
form of course I didn't want to play a
for wanted to take this looks weird now
okay let's grab a porn as long as I've
got the chance yeah bad just more slip
but it looks it looks ok could have
taken c3m know that I think of it but
it's a it's it's nice that's fine i've
got an extra ponent not much inside for
wider thing
maybe I can even get some some some
attiki on the edge file yeah this is
quite nice yass gotta move now I have
one root page 1 checkmate g3 I can just
take and here can also just take whom I
should have taken a bit more time here
of course I could have instead of taking
h3 I could have taken g4 and just win
okay but this is so so nice
look F and made yep this was the
quickest thing so five minutes to go
okay be known yet Bishop d7 SS just not
working but it's a to only do to
celebrate this is still a messy position
I'm just a piece up but you see it's a
very open disposition so I'm so not so
easy okay Queenie to put King d7 camel
let's develop him
yeah he's got some pawns miss King King
position is very insecure but he's got
three pawns yeah but this this looks
very very nice now 95 just 95 must be
good yeah okay I'll take the Queen if
you insist nice so four minutes left and
I think if ever get one more win in then
I should have should have done it this
is nice considering the bad start with
six minutes lost for nothing and on
minus three now I'm getting getting
again oh sorry chess and so it's always
dangerous it's quite quite a quick
player
it's not the most dangerous opening ever
what is playing here but it's a always I
can get some kind of heck going my
experience so Bishop g3 would be very
nice if you allowed this ok take it what
is he doing here
or the slips lock just winning no I
don't draw I just hit the wrong button i
put happens even accidentally resigned
before so this almost I mean this might
be enough already maybe I need to win
this game but even without it it should
be okay yeah I've got some Queens gambit
exchange here keep it 5 i'm using the
Sun square here yeah I want to get to
position where I have a good great night
here against this Bishop it's not soup I
mean this Bishop is a super terrible but
the night only five is so quite quite
nice
to check out one minute something left
so my deaf 7 I could have played not
have seven but this is this is threat
now maybe I can win the Queen quickly
looks like a total disaster really
yeah completely completely over this
should should be completely over but he
somehow still finds moves oh but this
this is enough now yeah my maid next
move and that's it this must be over 10
seconds left and I'm 20-something points
I had young okay but this will get
terminated this game quite sure why it
is continuing right I've done it the
first place very nice I haven't gone
first place for a while yeah well I made
it to some some rocky start and had the
silly time loss sorry if you got
offended by my cursing after this but
was just it's my own stupidity are not
looking at the clock but yeah what can
you do well thanks thanks for watching
was a quite a good tournament at the end
got to cut into the flow and yeah well
see you soon a new video